next up is Marvel talking about new
year's resolution so that's that's
timely here he's he said it's trying to
change his approach this year to focus
on not making a list of resolutions of
making a list of mistakes and
explanations to look at why he's not why
he didn't follow through on making those
plans and fixing the mistakes from last
year what are what are our thoughts and
how do you go about making resolutions
or even do you for the new year Gino for
the new year I'm gonna try one thing of
it because I'm so conscious I bust my
chops i'll be honest i demand a lot from
myself i never think when I look at
myself I've done well enough and that's
got a deeply ingrained in my psyche I
think and this is advice I'd give to
everybody when you look at yourselves
we've got great people today join us for
the blab i think i'm going to try in the
new year to say not for me but for other
people just look for the good things
they did and it's almost back to it
sports you know if you're competing
against karna validate say you say
involved for the hundred meters do you
beat yourself up all the time on that
one hundred of the second we don't come
out the blood or do you celebrate the
things that you do well in the last 50
meters where you accelerate away from
everybody else in the field I think we
should arm as leaders focus way more on
the things we do well and make them even
better and if we do that I think we'll
find we let's make miss less makes make
less mistakes and also any sort of
improvements we need you could call them
whatever you want with it we've all got
weaknesses but you if you accentuate the
positives if you accentuate and if
you've got people working for you in
your businesses if you just give them a
bit of phrase about what efforts they
put into achieving something that was
connected to your big passion and dream
and idea then wow you'll make them rise
forty thousand foot and fly out of your
home office and they'll be able to rule
the world and I think so often when I
look and I'd say this for myself in
terms of one
learning for me it's so easy to you know
say oh you did this okay but I want to
tell you about these three things that
you didn't do so good and and the voice
in your head because a lot of overcoming
the fear is smashing down the walls and
smashing those voices that tell you you
can't do stuff because you know you can
you know you can and if you keep on
listening to the voices around you're in
your head they'll just grind you down
and and you can lose the will to live so
I do think actually both for yourself
it's really good to celebrate the
positive save at the moment but most of
what you got you know you're a company
of two three five people wouldn't it be
powerful when you want a big order to
take everybody out for dinner and just
celebrate that enjoy and say your
contribution was this and if we hadn't
won that and you know maybe a pitch or
it may be the product they invented or
whatever is so powerful to galvanize the
people together against your passion for
your dream and I think so if one thing i
do is in terms of the new year's
resolution yeah okay spent maybe twenty
percent your time when you do that on
the one mistake but actually spend
eighty percent of your time on the
things you did really really well and
then you become a super trained athlete
to do them ever better and you know
focus on the positive to a stevens point
i would encourage you to not just wait
till the new year's resolution to come
around to start doing it like if Stephen
inspired you with that story about
celebrating the win then today is a
resolution like do it right now so many
people wait until new to start something
and then and then they fall off track a
couple weeks in I would love for you
guys listening and watching for
entrepreneurs to when you get an idea
just go out and and try it like even
even if you don't know all the details
right so I want to celebrate a win okay
great is it gonna be at a restaurant is
it going to be with the gift certificate
or we're going to like you start getting
you start planning all the things out
the perfectionist and us planned all the
things that we make it some big thing
and then because it's so big we never do
it because that's would be the perfect
thing and we never do anything and I
think just starting something small it
could be a phone call it could be it
someone taking somebody out it could be
just buying them
starbucks whatever just try something
see how it feels and adjust and I would
love for you guys to get the habit of
constantly doing a self-evaluation and
checking yourself and not waiting until
New Year's or your birthday or some
other arbitrary day like just start
doing you get inspired by something here
today take action I mean that would make
both Stephen and myself insanely happy
that's the goal right don't wait another
you know a couple weeks do something
today yeah I think evident as well
that's such a great point and you know
another great quote never leave till
tomorrow what could be done today and I
think yeah why wait to new year if this
is a great holiday season and for you
guys who have got customers out there
and if you got you know people working
for you colleagues the work for you and
follow your dream what a golden time to
say a really heartfelt thank you in the
holiday season it's sort of a time to
pause reflect they're going to go home
with their families or you know friends
and it's a really a pretty cool time to
pick up the phone to customers send him
a SMS or a direct message just saying
you know thank you so much for your
customer this year I'm really excited
about working with you again in 2017 so
is this a great time just with the not
just the new year for the end of the
year just to celebrate what you've
achieved this year really you know
recognize a few of the people like
especially your customers and the people
who have built that which is the people
you employ and just say thank you very
much it's a good time and now I think
everybody wants to feel valued and the
more you do that again it is it's kind
of with this is our flywheel of
positivity because if you say that to
your colleagues and you say that to
customer they're feeling the love for
your big idea and they'll give you great
feedback